everybody what is going on welcome to
another Bitcoin investing video as usual
I'm gonna have some of my live trading
going on in the background and I've also
even got the beta version of my machine
learning algorithm here for Bitcoin
prices going on too so you get a little
teaser of that now I want to build on
the last video in the idea of long-term
investing prospects with Bitcoin or even
if you're not interested in investing
totally the question is should you even
be trading Bitcoin it is it just
insanely risky to be having any of your
money in Bitcoin so in the last video I
explained why the u.s. dollars is pretty
problematic and I did this not only to
discuss the dollar itself but also what
you know regulated currency can bring to
the table because it is a little bit of
a risk to move to an unregulated
currency sometimes it does help to have
some sort of authoritative figure in
there that can kind of help with
problems because not all of the
government is just evil right although
some people would say that so anyway and
even if Bitcoin isn't you know the
perfect solution to all of these
problems it should shed some light on
the imperfection of the system that we
you know currently accepts so the next
thing that a lot of people bring up when
it comes to Bitcoin is the quote unquote
extreme volatility of these crypto
currencies this is why we can't it can't
be adopted because of this that's what I
want to discuss next
so Bitcoin isn't inherently volatile
there's nothing in the system of Bitcoin
that makes it volatile the volatility in
Bitcoin is coming from the increasing
popularity it's new and people are
they're very speculative about Bitcoin
but really we've yet to see Bitcoin for
example go on like a massive decline
that didn't just happen after a massive
rise now what's causing these Rises well
is it people jumping on bitcoins rise
you know purely because it's rising so
they like trying to just make a quick
buck or is it more people
hearing about Bitcoin and Bitcoin
actually gaining popularity you know
people can't buy something if they don't
know it exists and they probably won't
buy something that they've never even
heard about either or hardly ever heard
about right so my argument here is it
because not rising because of pure
speculation or because people are buying
into Bitcoin because it's rising hoping
to make a quick buck
I think Bitcoin has risen so much
because awareness of Bitcoin has risen
right that's that's really it you know
and people believe in Bitcoin people
buying into it causes a rise yes but
it's not for the reason that people keep
claiming right you know people like to
compare Bitcoin to tulipmania right so
tulip mania was pretty simple it's just
a massive speculative bubble where the
price of us like a single tulip bulb
reached prices of you know over like a
twenty times a typical person's salary
well that's quite a bit for a little
bulb for a flower right first of all
bitcoin is nowhere near this kind of
comparison at all I mean yes it has
risen quite a bit but we're not paying
absurd prices like 20 times a typical
person's salary if that's the case if
that's what it takes to make a bubble
then bitcoin is a long way to go because
the graph looks similar Bitcoin must be
an example of Bitcoin mania right well
by this standard a lot of startup
companies must be a form of tulip mania
how about Tesla what about Twitter I
mean jeez Twitter has is a killing
Bitcoin and growth and Twitter loses
money as a businessman it's it's like a
model it doesn't even work yet but
people are investing in it because of
growth right they there's more users
coming to Twitter and they're buying
into the growth of Twitter but people
are buying this because of Twitter's
growth they're optionality the eye that
they can turn to make a profit but and
this sort of idea seems super easy for
people to adopt when it comes to a
company like Twitter yet the same
websites and newspapers and journalists
and stuff like this you know held this
non profiting company like Twitter up on
a pedestal and they slam Bitcoin because
it's you know that's that's the thing to
do right now slam Bitcoin
right and and and now this isn't my
thing isn't meant to slam Twitter either
as an investment the point is that
there's more to there's more to a
company than a graph and again just like
the US dollar you know people keep you
know saying all bitcoins not good
bitcoins not good well what if we
compare it to the US dollar that thing
that everyone's using right now because
I mean no system is gonna be perfect
it's gonna be really hard to get like
you know that just perfect system
anyways so what we want to do is find a
good system you know something that's
gonna be the best option right and
bitcoin is already a working system it's
cutting out the transaction fees it's
and that transfers even without fees
beating the transfer time of bank
transfers but you can also pay a you
know a small fee and get your transfer
of Bitcoin to increase dramatically
Bitcoin is growing in popularity
just like mentioned as we compared it to
Twitter and even Twitter's growth is
pretty contended it allows for micro
payments which were previously you know
near possible due to a minimum fees from
banks and PayPal and stuff like that in
credit cards and stuff like this right
so you couldn't even do micro
transactions and micro payments and I'll
talk more on micro payments in a little
bit if you don't know what those are
now bitcoin also protects your
transactions because they can't be
reversed and every sender and receiver
is confirmed by the network itself and
so it's it's very secure transaction
that even occurs right and yes there
have been some scenarios where the
Bitcoin price changed quickly within a
very short time period and this was
almost always due due to some sort of
specific news right and this is the same
with any other currency stock commodity
you know whatever so that point is kind
of silly and it gets even more silly
because there is a 100% you know way
around the risk at all to accept Bitcoin
and convert it to US dollar so don't see
that as a worthy point so so people
claim you know that the merchants can't
use Bitcoin because they wouldn't know
what bitcoin would be worth the next day
or even like the next hour right so
because Bitcoin can
10% an hour no problem right
so merchants can't be dealing with that
kind of risk to their margin that's
understandable and so you see people say
this or journalists say this or you'll
see it in comments and stuff like that
and this point is made by people who've
considered this and gave it some thought
but then they didn't actually research
it so a service like coinbase
is there for this reason you can connect
a coin base as a merchant you can accept
Bitcoin and have that Bitcoin
immediately converted to your dollar of
choice it's actually converted
automatically before you even get it
this basically ensures you as the
merchants against having to deal and
actually keep up with the Bitcoin market
you get what you want and people can pay
with Bitcoin there's no risk at all and
I'll bring this up a little bit more in
the next video we'll be talking a bit
more about it but also you know you
can't charge a Bitcoin back I don't know
how many of you guys are merchants but
the thing I hate the most about
especially like PayPal is they don't
protect protect the seller at all
against chargebacks I mean there's a few
chances for seller protection but for
the most part there's there's no there's
no help right I've lost every single
case of charge back and then and what's
worse if someone charged backs with a
credit card you're totally screwed
because not only do you lose that money
the credit card company charges you a
fee of like 20 bucks for their efforts
and and and just to drive the point home
they're not charging you 20 bucks just
for the hell of it they're charging you
20 bucks because the actual
investigation of that transaction costs
close to $20 in efficiency not good so
before you say that merchants won't
actually accept this kind of stuff you
should definitely first you know either
be a merchant with merchants problems or
or or or do the research and find out
what's actually available for merchants
who want to allow Bitcoin because in the
end the fees incurred with the service
if you use something like coinbase
or even less than using paypal credit
card whatever because if you McCoy bases
1% yet the merchant is actually more
protected it's a better choice for the
merchants and so if anything merchants
who learn about Bitcoin would be
extremely enticed by the lesser fees
increased seller protection and along
with that
they are increasing their customer base
right so there's really nothing to lose
for them at all plus it just looks like
your new age and cool when you can say I
said Bitcoin and so so the merchants and
their options are gonna be discussed a
little bit more in the next video
especially with coinbase since a lot of
people would have more questions about
that so now to bring this Bitcoin case
of volatility home a little bit here's a
chart that I'm sure you guys have seen a
few times if you've been looking into
Bitcoin so this is the Bitcoin pricing
chart pay no attention to the missing
bottom indicator and missing top
indicator for now so this is the Bitcoin
price now wouldn't it be nice if we
there was like some sort of program
where we could literally see into the
future of like what is gonna happen to
this price well it just so happens that
I have that program here and so let's
see let's just literally scroll into the
future and see what happens this price
so it does indeed go down quite a bit
after this point oh man it's pretty
pretty dangerous-looking so it continues
going down oh my gosh it goes way down
look how far down it goes and then let's
see and continues again starts kind of
reviving itself it looks like so it's
not going up now so I'm predicting the
future as we speak and we continue on
and whoa whoa now it's going way up oh
my gosh this is a bubble now if this
isn't a bubble I don't know what is guys
oh my gosh look at this bubble oh my
okay so what would I need to do we need
to zoom out we definitely need to zoom
out a little bit so let me let's see if
we can't zoom out a little bit here so
here's our bubble let me let me get in
on this bubble now so now so now we've
seen that actually as we've moved into
the future we've gone through one bubble
now we're going through a second bubble
right here and it just so happens that
well I can predict the future even more
and I'm gonna go through this bubble and
this one seems to be faring a little
better than that previous bubble huh but
it's still actually stropping down oh
we've lost it's gone off the screen
that's how bad this bubble was and then
maybe I shouldn't zoom at some more
brutal here we go
oh oh oh this looks like another bubble
guys what is happening and it looks like
we have reached the end of my futuristic
prediction so let me go ahead and zoom
this entire graph out for us what are we
looking at we're looking to the entirety
of the Bitcoin historical prices so
starting off I would have showed you
guys this is unlike somebody's website
but I was finding a pretty hard time
finding like a full chart and some of
the charts were actually very tricky
they didn't actually show you like the
full historical it's like after this
bubble it did kind of come down to a
pretty miniscule price right $5 here a
lot of people would start it like here
right but my point with is showing you
guys this chart is actually we've seen
this this kind of hockey stick chart
multiple times very early on we saw it
right here so that was the first one I
showed you guys and then we predicted
the future so there's another bubble
there here was another quote-unquote
bubble looking even more similar to what
we're looking at right now Crashdown
lolled out how about another bubble
that's this bubble that we're in right
now right here apparently so here's the
prices that we've seen so it you know
got all the way up and this is the other
thing too that bothers means people you
know quote mount gawk says it you know
the price went over you know 1200 well
yeah i'm mount GOx it did anyway so so
here is just some example of you know I
just wanted to show you guys the prices
here and what happened on every bubble
you know this was also a bubble right
here by the way but the bubble popped
right all the bubble pops here too and
all in here you know so just because the
graph looks like this doesn't really
mean much you still have to decide how
you feel about you know what is Bitcoin
so hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
video learn something new if you like my
videos and want to continue seeing some
more videos subscribe if you like them
enough there is a Bitcoin donations
address in the description as always
thanks for watching and until the next
video